in the 90s moviegoers have plenty of
opportunities to watch everything from
little green men to big scary space
monsters
to that end here's a list of 90s alien
movies that should be required viewing
the year is sometime in the 23rd century
and in its quest for interplanetary
colonization
humankind stumbled across a hostile
alien species
of giant insects known as bugs
when it's reported that the bugs have
destroyed buenos aires with an asteroid
killing millions in the process a bunch
of sexy young people and less than the
military to go kick some anthropod butt
awesome action lessons in leadership and
more than one topless scene ensue
this is the plot of 1997 starship
troopers
directed by the legendary filmmaker paul
verhoeven who graced us with such genre
gems as basic instinct
showgirls and of course robocop the
movie gives us as much as you're willing
to get out of it
if you're looking for a b movie filled
with hot actors hooking up and fighting
aliens in spectacular battles
you'll get it by the truck starship load
and if you're looking for a bit of death
there's actually a surprisingly
subversive critique of fascist power
structures
hidden among all the special effects and
steamy scenes starship troopers is a
hilarious shredding rom that has a
healthy dose of smuts it does however
have a string of straight to video
sequels
of significantly diminished quality that
you can feel free to skip
it was one of the most quoted movies of
1996 and possibly
even the entire decade what child of the
90s hasn't shouted welcome to earth at
least once
it's independence day and there's one
explosive thrill ride
let's set the scene when dozens of 50
mile wide alien spaceships descend upon
the earth
and simultaneously wipe out major cities
with massive laser beams
things are looking grim for humankind as
the ships reposition to destroy more
cities
it becomes a race against time to figure
out their weaknesses and fight back
boasting an absolutely stacked cast
featuring the likes of will smith
jeff goldblum bill pullman and many more
independence day was a smash hit
raking in 817.4 million dollars at the
box office
which made it not only the highest
grossing film of 1996
but the second highest grossing film
ever at the time
today we celebrate our independence day
of course 20 years later we got the
release of independence day resurgence
which nobody asked for and nobody wanted
to see without leading man will smith
the sequel was doomed to fail from the
get-go
and in the end it got bad reviews and
flopped at the box office
so by all means watch independence day
but don't feel bad if you decide to stop
there
in 1979 aliens set the standard for
modern sci-fi movies and catapulted lead
sigourney weaver to super stardom
in 1986 aliens up the ante by expanding
the woman vs mysterious alien premise
to people versus tons of aliens plus
loads of guns
with thrilling results then in 1992
alien 3 confounded its filmmakers and
audiences alike
by throwing way too many cooks into the
kitchen resulting in a movie that
at the time was panned for its
questionable script disjointed pacing
and storytelling
and general lack of excitement don't be
afraid
i'm part of the family all of that being
said retrospective reappraisals have
found much to appreciate in alien 3.
largely because the extended cut that
came out some years later
proved that the movie director david
fincher wanted to make was much better
than anyone understood at the time
narratively speaking alien 3 was pretty
straightforward
weaver's character ripley crashes on a
remote prison planet where it turns out
that her escape pod has a stowaway
xenomorph egg inside
said egg impregnates a dog resulting in
a neat canine alien hybrid
that forces the prisoners to band
together and fight for their lives
pretty cool right unfortunately the
movie was plagued by production problems
cycling through screenwriters
cinematographers and directors like a
game of musical chairs
when now renowned director david fincher
finally got a hold of it
he did everything he could to write the
course behind the scenes meddling
however took its toll
but alien 3 turns out to be an
interesting tonal shift
for the series taking on an almost
gothic feel and many of the plot
choices are genuinely daring the fact
that it introduced the world to the
great david fincher is in itself reason
enough to put it on your list
after arriving on earth the first order
of business for our alien visitors is to
vaporize the us congress before
attempting to take over the entire
planet this might sound like the plot of
a horror movie but mars attacks is
anything but scary
in fact it's an outright ridiculous romp
released in 1996 mars attacks was
director tim burton's attempt at making
a 50's style sci-fi b
movie in the vein of the day the earth
stood still or plan 9 from outer space
and it leaned hard into that b-movie
distinction mars attacks is absurd to
the extreme
weaving together a range of unlikely
subplots about people
who are almost always doomed due to
their own idiocy attempting to survive
the extraterrestrial induced chaos the
cast is incredible
boasting a-list names that include jack
nicholson glenn close
annette benning p.s brosnan martin short
michael j
fox natalie portman and more but even
with all that star power the film was a
flop
critics scorned it and it holds a mere
54 percent
on rotten tomatoes it didn't perform any
better at the box office
bringing home just 101 million dollars
worldwide
on its 80 million dollar budget but
don't let any of that deter you
mars attacks is a must see if for no
other reason to experience one of the
weirdest watches of the 90s in 1975
lagers in rural arizona panic and flee
when their co-worker is blasted by a ray
of light from an unidentified flying
object
upon returning to the scene a said
co-worker is nowhere to be found and
when the loggers report the
incident to the local police they are of
course the primary suspects in the man's
disappearance
he reappears a few days later incoherent
and clothingless
eventually relating in extreme detail
that had been abducted by aliens
travis can we have your autograph
autograph yeah you're famous you've been
to space
this was the story of the infamous
walton incident which alleged abductee
travis walton detailed in a book that in
1993
was made into the film fire in the sky
in a decade full of alien and sci-fi
blockbusters
fire in the sky was a relatively small
movie with its 15 million dollar budget
and it was nothing short of a box office
flop bringing in just 19.8 million
dollars worldwide
reviews at the time were mixed and today
it has a mere 42 percent on rotten
tomatoes
so what about fire in the sky makes it
so necessary to watch if it's so
completely underperformed
it's simple the intense alien abduction
flashback after the abductee returns and
recovers his senses he relates in
extreme detail his experience on the
alien examination table as his captors
perform various experiments
while the rest of the movie is
admittedly a bit lukewarm it's
definitely worth it to check out this
one squirmworthy scene
it's a sleek silly over-the-top sci-fi
rom that inspired orange-haired
revealing halloween costumes for decades
to come
it won awards at both the prestigious
cannes film festival
and the golden raspberry awards its
creator luke bassan began writing it
when he was just 16 years old
and it opened as a number one movie in
the us more than 20 years later
it's the fifth element and there's no
other movie quite like it
set some 200 years in the future the
fifth element tells the story
of corbin dallas an ex-soldier and down
on his lug flying taxi driver
who's thrust into adventure when a young
mysterious woman named lilu
literally falls into his life dallas
comes to learn that lilu is the key to
stopping an evil force that threatens to
destroy
earth and they set off on a ridiculous
quest to save the planet
and we're not exaggerating when we use
the word ridiculous on one hand
the fifth element is an exciting space
thriller but on the other
it's a slapstick comedy a lot of three
stooges gary oldman plays one of the
most purposely laughable villains in
movie history
and chris tucker takes absurdity to new
heights as a shrieking flamboyantly
wisecracking intergalactic talk show
host
ruby rod this boy is fueled
like fire they'll start melting ladies
because the boy is hotter than her
as the director explained himself it's
not a quote a big theme movie
instead the point is more or less to
offer adventure for the sake of
adventure
with plenty of jokes on top the fifth
element delivers which is why it still
has a devoted fan base more than 20
years after its release
no matter what decade it happens to be
the buddy cop concept
generally turns out to be a winner you
know the formula a pair of mismatched
law men get paired up
one of whom is the straight lace square
and the other is the quirky risk taker
along the way they learn to appreciate
one another while saving the day
in 1997 men in black took this recipe
and spiced it up by turning the cops
into a duo
of secret government agents and by
pitting them against you guessed it
aliens you sold a reverberating
carbonizer with mutant capacity to an
unlicensed cephalopod james you piece of
it looked alright to me it started tommy
lee jones as a straight man
and will smith as a loose cannon and the
results couldn't have been more perfect
the premise was pretty simple new to the
men in black secret agency
smith has partnered up with jones and
the pair are tasked with finding a
mysterious device called the galaxy
before it falls into the wrong alien
hands or tentacles or whatever
the adventure that ensues is as
hilarious as it is thrilling
men in black was a massive success
earning universally positive reviews
and raking in the bugs at the box office
this success resulted in a sequel that
was panned by critics
as the first installment was praised and
while the third attempt was an
improvement on the sequel
the fourth go-round was just plain bad
all three of the sequels were released
in the 2000s and 2010s though
so maybe men in black was a 90s only
sort of thing
what happens when the fans of your
science fiction tv series take it too
seriously
while this is an issue that many a star
trek alumnus has had to grapple with
it's unlikely that william shatner or
leonard nimoy ever had to deal with
extraterrestrial obsession
but that's exactly what happened to the
crew of the protector in 1999's galaxy
quest
you guys came who wants the grand tour
when the washed up cast from a once
popular sci-fi show is mistaken for the
real deal
by an alien species that confuse
television for reality
the actors are plugged from their lives
and taken aboard an actual spaceship
their outer space audience has amicably
abducted them
hoping for their help in fighting off a
terrifying foe and
soon the cast is embroiled in an
authentic intergalactic adventure
while galaxy quest parodies sci-fi
series like star trek
it was widely acclaimed by trekkies and
non-trekkies alike
in addition to lead star tim allen the
cast was stacked with talents like
sigourney weaver
alan rickman sam rockwell daryl mitchell
and tony shalhoub
simultaneously smart hilarious and
exciting it was a critical and
box-office success
and some embrace was it by star trek
aficionados that they voted at the
seventh best star trek movie of all time
no one likes high school but for the
kids and the faculty high school
truly is a killer i think something's
taking over our school
body snatches is a story somebody made
up thing is it's located in the fiction
section of the line yeah
so there's list the premise is simple
after discovering a strange unidentified
parasite
a handful of students at harrington high
begin to notice that their teachers and
classmates
aren't acting like themselves it turns
out that they aren't themselves as their
bodies are gradually being taken over by
an invading alien force
it's invasion of the body snatchers but
for teens armed only with an unnamed
drug manufactured by one of the students
that kills the aliens for some reason
these students have to save their school
and the world before it's too late
released in 1998 the faculty performed
well at the box office
but it was hit or miss with both critics
and audiences alike
roughly half of which leveled the charge
that the movie was too cliche
but for many viewers that was also its
strength paying homage to a tradition of
sci-fi horror thrillers that didn't take
themselves too seriously
admittedly the faculty isn't brilliant
nor is all that original
but it's an undeniably fun watch and hey
jon stewart makes a cameo it also has
the distinction of being among the
earliest films by now renowned director
robert rodriguez check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one